there's actually a really good reason
your shampoo bottle says rinse and
repeat on the back hi I have a PhD in
super molecular chemistry so this is my
area a lot of people tagged me in this
video that says you need to shampoo
twice according to science you don't
there is nothing in the science that
says one wash with surfactants can't get
all the oil and dirt off and it's
actually what is shown in this diagram
everything is coming off with just the
one wash in terms of chemistry it is the
same as when you're washing dishes
dishes don't necessarily need to be
washed twice it depends on how dirty the
plate is your Technique the product
you're using so if it just isn't very
good at cleaning or if you didn't use
enough then you might need to wash it
twice and it even depends on things like
the temperature of the water so you
might find that your hair and scalp are
happier if you do wash twice but most
shampoos are designed to wash well with
just the one wash